it's an honor really to be kicking off
data Council this year every year I come
by and look at all of the amazing people
that are building together all of the
amazing Founders and companies that are
represented here and it's really
exciting to go through like three days
of this learning process to understand
what's going on with data all of the
exciting stuff that everyone is building
and all of the excitement that's yet to
come
unfortunately my Keynote
is not about all of the excitement that
generative AI probably could be doing
and like building a control plane for us
it's actually about simplifying a lot of
stuff that we've jointly maybe made a
bit more exciting than it needs to have
been
so the talk is called building a control
plane for data
and I'm going to be talking about what a
control plane is why we need it and how
we can build it
Pete already talked about who I am so I
won't belabor that too much but my whole
time at LinkedIn I found myself fighting
two forces the first force was trying to
make data easy to use also known as data
democracy right and the other force was
trying to make data hard to use for the
wrong reasons which is you know privacy
and compliance and a lot of the work
that I did there led me to create the
datahub project
and for those who are not familiar with
the data Hub project
it's an open source metadata platform
that powers data Discovery data
observability and data governance modern
data governance we like to call it for a
lot of companies on top of a high
fidelity metadata graph and accurate
data is a company that's advancing the
datahip project of course with the help
of a large group of Open Source
collaborators and contributors
and this is probably not the last time
you you'll hear me say metadata graph
today so let's talk about what that
graph looks like
of course at the center of it all is the
variable data set the you know the
center piece of any data ecosystem but
data sets come in various shapes and
sizes so there are you know streams and
tables and folders
with files in them and then associated
with them are schemas and columns and
business glossaries which allow you to
actually put logical structure on top of
it and that as you go to the next level
you see queries
and uh pipelines and tasks and jobs and
dashboards
and ml models
and data quality assertions all of these
like consumable artifacts that a data
practitioner actually creates to make
data easy to use
and then in the outer reaches our
identity systems obviously users groups
roles privileges
and then finally even more abstract
Concepts like data products and data
contracts and all of these things are
starting to get pulled in into this
single metadata graph
and of course it's not just a graph
that's static it's continuously changing
and data Hub has essentially evolved to
represent all of this complexity
in one unified way
and allowed for it to change over time
so encoding versions and temporality
into the single graph
if you look at it you know it really
represents everything that the
data-driven Enterprise cares about all
the way from an executive to a Hands-On
practitioner who's you know deploying a
DBT model to production with an airflow
Dag
um and this is what the data Hub
application looks like you know it's got
a search and Discovery experience on top
of this metadata graph so you can kind
of find everything that you need across
the entire ecosystem
you can see end-to-end lineage all the
way from your apis to your dashboards
and your ml models
and you can also look at operational
history of an activity within your data
pipeline so which pipelines have landed
how they're doing what the slas look
like things like that
so that probably gave you a quick sense
of what datahub is as a product
and you know the industry is taking
notice and it has quickly evolved to
becoming uh very popular by all
standards uh the number one open source
metadata platform uh and a lot of it is
obviously because of the breadth of
Integrations it has but also because of
the fact that you can solve multiple use
cases with the same platform so we have
got companies obviously like LinkedIn
and Pinterest and stripe
and newer companies like Peloton and
notion who are starting out on their
data Journey starting to adopt it and
it's uh it's been pretty exciting to see
kind of the growth over the last couple
of years
so you might be wondering well that's
great now I know what data Hub is I know
that there's a metadata graph behind it
and I know that some problems have been
solved well but what does that have to
do with the control plane of data right
and to answer that we have to go back a
few years you know like a decade or so
I want to take a little bit of time to
talk about how we got to here if you
remember
in the last decade or so a rallying cry
as an industry has been you know the
three vs volume variety velocity
and so as an industry we really have
been working really hard to make data
easy to consume easy to store massive
amounts of scale
and then easy to process and then
transform whether it's structured or
unstructured
Accenture I mean I looked this up on the
Internet Accenture did a study and they
found that
in 2009 the planet
only had digital capacity to store
what is it 487
exabytes of data total
that seems like a large number actually
like you know in 2009 we had the ability
to store
exactly
487 exabytes of data
and the same firm projected that in by
we would be generating
almost the same amount every day
so that's how far we've come
as an industry I mean if the data is
reliable
of course data quality joke 10 minutes
into the talk yeah did that
but
I mean I don't know how they got those
numbers but if those numbers are true
it's it's quite impressive what we've
done
and what we've done you know all of us
builders
is gone from here you know Matt Turk
bless his soul kind of catalogs the
state of the industry every year and so
this is what we looked like in 2012.
and I'm probably dating myself here but
I pretty much know all of these
companies
I know every one of them actually I
looked at them
and if you fast forward to 2021
this is what it looks like
this is what we've done
and so this ladies and gentlemen is the
modern data stack
right
we've we've innovated we've specialized
but then we'll also fragment it
right
so is this all good news or is it bad
news or is it mixed
actually a lot of things got easier you
know data storage is not something we
worry about anymore
we've got multiple blob stores we've got
nosql stores we've got stream storage
you know storing streams used to be a
problem and now it's not we've got a few
different streaming stores to choose
from
data movement
used to be a problem
we used to do dragging and dropping of
boxes and try to transform data in
flight and now we figured out faster and
more efficient ways of doing it invented
new categories along the way really when
people are trying to move data from one
point to another they're now not
thinking
can I do it they're thinking oh there's
a bunch of tools and I'm just going to
pick the one that works best for me
and that leads me to data querying which
is a very strange thing that has emerged
where we've experimented with so many
different paradigms we've done shared
nothing we've done uh disaggregated
storage compute we've done Federated and
then we've also done embedded DBS and
we've somehow managed to make all of
them work
and of course data visualization has had
a step function right looker finally
Bridge the git UI divide and I'm so
excited that we did things like that and
with newer tools like hex we're kind of
taking data authoring into almost a new
age
and then the list goes on right in each
of these segments orchestration I mean
airflow
brought python into orchestration and
Unleashed a whole new level of crazy and
then the newer wave of orchestrators are
kind of trying to peel back from that
and say hey hey let's get back some
declarative back into our worlds right
transformation had an interesting
Journey we kind of
fell out of love with SQL
tried mapreduce and some strange
lower level apis and now we're back with
SQL and some friends you know and by
friends I mean data frames and things
like that which have the framework
support to kind of bridge that
imperative declarative divide
and then real time is now a thing
streaming compute you no longer have to
really
choose fast and wrong
versus slow and correct right there's a
lot of work that has happened on doing
exactly ones guarantees and giving
correctness guarantees
and of course AI infra deserves like a
conference of its own
um but by torch Ray these things have
really made production ml a reality
so a lot of good things happen
and actually as I look out at the
audience here a lot of it happened
because of all of you so give yourself a
huge pattern on the back or a round of
applause for all of the Innovation that
you guys have done
to make all of these things possible
yeah
you deserve it a lot of a lot of hard
work a lot of money
float in and funded all of that hard
work so it's all good stuff
but like all good movies
there is a twist
some things got harder
some new problems got harder and some
old problems that were easier before are
now 10 times harder
and those three problems are data
discovery
data quality and data management
data discovery is kind of a term that
are the the data Community has sort of
coined for itself
is the problem that arises when you
want to understand what are all the data
assets that you have in your
organization how is it getting
transformed as it flows from one tool to
another
and what makes for a high quality or a
highly trusted data asset
so that's the problem that we've tried
to solve in this data Discovery bucket
and I don't know if you were here last
year but Maggie and I had a talk
called the data practitioners guide to
data Discovery and we we had this slide
up there describing you know as a
community when we tried to solve these
problems what were the things that we
got wrong in the first attempt
and there are a few things in there and
I'll not go into all of the details but
at a high level
there are multiple personas
that need metadata
you need physical technical as well as
business metadata and there are
different personas that have different
needs from it
so trying to solve it by integrating all
of the metadata in one place and then
giving multiple personas different views
on it those kind of things were not
tried early on
similarly architecturally we had a lot
of emphasis on just crawling metadata
and that led to a lot of staleness and
lack of trust in the quality of the data
Discovery solution itself
in addition there was no approach to
actually respond to changes that were
happening in the metadata so the
applicability of the metadata stayed
locked in only to the tool that was
integrating it
and finally we paid too much attention
to data consumers we told data consumers
come to this UI click this button curate
the documentation
and all of that was good but in many
cases they were just cleaning up the
messes left by the data producers
who were willfully generating new data
assets and forgetting to document it or
not describing what they were actually
putting into their data tables
and so a lot of this stuff seemed
reactive and thankless
and finally data Discovery Solutions
have traditionally been very over
indexed on the data warehouse like
everything has to be in the warehouse so
let's just focus there try to help data
Discovery work over there but the
reality is data in the warehouse is
coming from some other place it's coming
from your operational systems your
streaming ecosystem maybe your
third-party tools and if you don't
include them as part of your scope
you're going to be missing a big part of
the picture
so data Hub of course has a very
opinionated take to it towards it and we
think we're doing quite well there uh we
have you know a three-phased approach to
solving this problem the first is you
know what we call metadata 360 borrowing
a term from you know other Industries
combining technical operational and
business metadata in one graph
the second is including data producers
in the act of actually creating this
metadata to begin with so shifting left
allowing someone who's checking in an
Avro or protobuf file to annotate it in
line with the compliance annotations all
the documentations or someone's checking
in a DVT model right in the meta section
adding in the column level tags and
things like that that way you're not
cleaning up stuff later
and finally enabling a real-time
continuously flowing metadata platform
allows you to have operational
Integrations allows other systems to
actually react when metadata changes
which makes metadata not be just a human
facing application but a program
programmatic construct that's flowing in
your data ecosystem
and so those three things
I think have done a lot to making
Discovery data Discovery be a hard
problem to being an almost solved close
to done problem
and data hub's architecture has evolved
obviously in reaction to kind of solving
these problems in this way if you look
under the covers essentially all of your
data sources up to the left are
producing events in some cases we have
to cheat and kind of
pull metadata out of those events but we
try to do it as fast as we can and
essentially there's a fire hose of
metadata events coming out of these
systems you know spark job and airflow
tasks those kind of things are emitting
events constantly
those get integrated into Data hubs
real-time metadata graph and then on
platform actions can start happening so
data sets that look similar to each
other can get reconciled you might have
a governance test that are running
continuously on top of this graph for
example you might just notice that a
data set landed and it breached its SLA
and you need to fire off an alert and
that can fire off an off-platform action
that sends a slack notification
or you might have a data set that got
tagged with pii and you want to
instantly lock down access to it in
bigquery or Snowflake and you can have
an agent that actually does that so a
lot of things Beyond just the data
Discovery application get enabled with
an architecture like this
so data Discovery went from being hard
to in my opinion pretty close to solved
but a few other things continue to stay
pretty hard let's talk about data
quality the second of the heart problems
that we've got
um so some companies don't really do
data quality but the companies that do
have
a lot of tools to choose from which is
great
data itself
travels through a lot of stages before
it becomes ready for consumption so this
is a very common kind of pattern we find
in the data Hub community
uh you might have you know your
streaming data in Kafka you might have a
Flink pipeline or some other pipeline
that's Landing that data set uh the
topic into the lake
you might then be loading that data up
into a warehouse like snowflake or
bigquery
and then maybe using DBT or something
else to you know process it further
and when you want to implement data
quality
onto this pipeline you end up injecting
the right rules or the right checks at
the right points in the life cycle of
the data set makes complete sense so you
might be doing some of these row
oriented checks like null checks or
other kinds of checks in during
ingestion itself so that you're not
Landing bad data into the lake at all
and then after data lands in the lake
you might be running like a table
oriented check maybe using Great
Expectations to do row count level
validation
and then maybe after loading it up into
bigquery you might be doing SQL based
checks doing cross data set validations
and things like that
and then for all the unknown unknowns
you might be using an anomaly detection
system to see what does normal look like
and what does a deviation look like an
alert based on that
so what's wrong with this picture I mean
nothing's wrong in isolation
we are using the best tool for the job
in every single part of the stack
but the problem is that we don't have a
unified view of whether this data set is
really high quality or not because
different tools have evaluated different
things
and so for a pipeline that is processing
a data set Downstream of this to have a
sense of what checks have been applied
what worked what didn't work it's it's
actually quite a hard problem
let's talk about data management and
data management is obviously a very
broad discipline and it includes things
like access management and table
retention and things like that but I'll
start with my favorite thing access
management
quick show of hands how many of you
are on AWS
cool
and how many of you have actually set up
access on AWS
much fewer group right because usually
you don't do it yourself you have
someone else do it for you because it's
very complicated
just setting up access management on AWS
once
is like nine steps or something and
these are screenshots from a YouTube
video that describes how easy it is to
set it up
and of course you don't just have AWS
you have probably looker and
data breaks and maybe Kafka and so
you've got to go repeat all of these
steps in all of these individual tools
again and again
and even the concepts are almost the
same but not quite like looker has
something called roles and permissions
but they don't quite work exactly the
same as how it works in snowflakes so
you have to make sure that you
understand what each individual system
means when they say roles or permissions
and that's just access management
add-on you know masking of sensitive
information
table based retention key based
retention which you need for gdpr and
then data locality
and you've got like job security
for a lot of people
when as a
stakeholder as someone who's answerable
to higher authorities all you want to
say is
all my EU data should only live on my EU
customer data should only live in EU and
all my data scientists should always
have access to customer data scrubbed of
pii right something as simple as that is
what you want to say but to actually
make it a reality is a ton of work and
you actually don't know if you're doing
it right
so those are the hard problems and the
question in front of us is how do we
solve for it
well a famous person once said and
actually this the lineage of this quote
is under question
because I could not find out who
actually ever said it but it is said
that someone said
that all problems in computer science
can be sought by another layer of
interaction so we should be able to do
it
and there are two steps to It Right Step
One is of course you need to understand
what's going on
in this complex data stack because
otherwise you don't have a Baseline
right so you need that visibility layer
that allows you to see every table
that's changing every schema that's
changing every data score data quality
score that's Landing
and then you need a way to declare what
you want to happen a logical to physical
translation layer and then have it get
applied down into this individual
physical tools
and of course you need to know that it
happened so you need feedback coming
back from your visibility layer into
your logical layer and once you have
that you've got a nice closed loop
you're able to declare what good looks
like you're then able to make good
happen and then you're able to assert
that good did indeed happen
and that actually is the definition of a
control plane a control plane
according to you know the definitional
guide says resides above the data plane
observes and enforces rules for the data
plane and that's exactly what we want
and the good news is this pattern
actually has been applied in other
domains and so we can learn from those
uh practices those implementations and
actually apply it to our data stack
the first place where this has been
applied is the service mesh of course
right so istio is a project that I don't
know how many people are familiar with
istio
good generally the data world and the
operational world are different so it's
good to know that a lot of people know
about istio it's you know it's a it
helps service measures actually become a
reality istio centralizes configuration
policy definitions things like that so
that you can have a bunch of services
that talk to each other even though
they're written in different languages
and you're able to assert properties
about the entire mesh
the second one that you're probably more
familiar with is terraform
so terraform kind of has made us very
comfortable with the fact that you can
declare
what needs to happen and then the system
makes that happen by applying those
logical statements into physical reality
so a developer can check in a terraform
script that says please give me an ec2
instance with this this much compute and
this much RAM and terraform will apply
settings along with centrally defined
rules to make that happen
so the good thing is we can learn a lot
from these systems
the first thing we can learn from them
is
be declarative right State what you know
separate out what centralized concerns
are like by default whenever we schedule
on ec2 these are the constraints we want
to have but then give the developer some
ability to configure what they really
need so declarative not imperative
the second thing that we've learned from
these systems is that anytime you
decentralize power and responsibility
just use software engineering principles
right version your stuff do policy as
code governance is code these kind of
things work so shift left and and give
your developers the ability to check in
these artifacts
and the final thing that we've learned
and that's kind of interesting I would
say
is that
oftentimes standardization
feels like
the only way to make tools work together
but systems like terraform have shown us
that the adapter pattern actually can be
used quite successfully you can get a
lot done by adapting a system against
every other system out there
so if you're with me so far we've kind
of gone through a few examples of
control planes in other domains now
let's apply those patterns to the data
plane right
a couple of things if we were to write
you know an engineering design doc for
okay let's Design This control plane
what are the characteristics it needs to
have the first characteristic that comes
to mind obviously is breadth right
clearly this thing has got to be
extremely broad it needs to integrate
with every system built by mankind and
coming ahead it also needs to represent
everything all of these complex
constructs inside of these systems and
it needs to embrace decentralization it
needs to allow for things to get
declared as artifacts that are checked
in as course controlled artifacts
it also needs to obviously be very low
latency because we need to be enabling
operational use cases I need to be able
to react to a change that happened right
away and stop bad things from happening
it needs to scale and this is an
interesting one most people don't
realize that but all of those exabytes
of data that we are producing every day
that actually generates
a pretty large amount of metadata
I mean a schema is not that large but as
you start tracking it's change over time
as you start tracking an ml model its
inputs and it outputs every single task
that happened every single task run that
happen that amount of metadata gets
large pretty quickly and so you have to
acknowledge that and design for it
the fourth characteristic is actually
you have to be a source of Truth for all
of those control specifications all of
those data contracts or data product
definitions or access policies that are
going to get declared and then uh
executed on you have to be the source of
Truth for all of those things
and finally of course you have to be
auditable
someone at any point in time who looks
at the system in a particular State
should be able to say
this is why
Chris did not get access to that data
set
whether that access happened before
whether they had access to this data set
before whether they will have access to
it in the future
all of that needs to be answered using
the auditability infrastructure in the
control plane
so those are our capabilities
now let's try to see can we quickly
sketch up a design for how we would
build this thing
so that's what I call the architecture
blueprint right
the first requirement is actually kind
of simple and hopefully you'll kind of
see where this is going the first thing
we need is real-time visibility and
breadth so you've got your data plane
you need event oriented signal
collection from all of it
and because you need to really account
for all of the scale and breadth you
need a metadata graph with versioning
time-oriented nature and change
subscription built into it so other
operational use cases can be enabled so
solving for real-time visibility in
bread seems kind of simple we've seen
this pattern before
now you add in The Logical to physical
translation layer
I need logical specifications to be
checked in somewhere a retention
specification an SLA specification a
data quality specification those
specifications need to get registered
with the control plane so the control
plane needs to accept them validate them
say that this looks good
and then once that has been accepted
operators or providers or you know pick
your favorite actor term needs to get
triggered and those things need to do
things
based on the contracts that just came in
or the control specifications that just
came in and they need to move the system
from its current state into the ideal
state
and for that you need State Management
Primitives as part of the control plane
infrastructure
so putting it all together you've got
control specifications registering into
the control plane
which has metadata graph storage
capabilities gives you State Management
capabilities you've got operators
sitting outside of it that are acting on
those things that are changing making
changes happen into the data plane
events come back out of the data plane
allows us to get unified auditing and
alerting
so that we know at any stage in time
what's going on
so that's the architecture blueprint for
how you build a control plane and just
to prove that we can do this I'll go
through a few use cases some of the use
cases that I talked about earlier in the
talk and we'll walk through this really
quickly but hopefully it'll kind of
Click for you that hey we can do this
with this architecture
the first one is a simple one reliable
data pipelines imagine you've got two
tables table a and table B
they're getting joined together in
another airflow job that's Downstream of
it and let's say table a is getting
evaluated by some data quality operator
out of band
and table B is getting actually
evaluated in for its data quality by the
ingestion system that's Landing table B
now all we need to do is have these two
data Quality Systems independent systems
report what happened right report the
quality results back into the control
plane
and the airflow task that is starting up
later needs to just subscribe to a
couple of things it needs to subscribe
to the data set arrival signal so did
table a arrive did table B arrive and
then and then
did the data quality scores for those
two tables arrive and that gives you
essentially that 360 degree view that
allows you to understand
is it now the right time to proceed and
compute this join that I was about to do
or should I wait or should I actually
declare failure because the Upstream
table isn't of high quality so this is a
simple one
mostly on the observability side
and now we add specifications on top of
it so imagine you know we come up with
some data contract specification that
says here's the schema of the Kafka
topic Dr control plane please make it so
right we register that data contract to
the control plane
and a data contract operator gets
triggered the data contract operator
knows that there's a contract change
event that has happened
it uses that to initiate either
enforcement or monitoring of the schema
for that Kafka topic and it starts
reporting results back
now since everything is logged in our
metadata chain stream we have unified
alerting and auditing that tells us
whether this schema is actually matching
the the table that we have or whether
it's failing a more complex example of
this would be the operator might
actually start up a Flink job
that starts comparing the input rows to
the output rows and maybe creating a
dead letter q or things like that so
what the data contract operator triggers
is kind of up to you depending on what
you want to do but this is how the flow
would look like
now let's add on SLA monitoring on top
of this we've got a Kafka data set a
Kafka topic and there's a bigquery table
that's Downstream of it and we want to
assert that this bigquery table must
arrive by 7 am every morning it's a
common SLA use case
so you add that on to your control
specification the control plane takes it
registers it an SLA monitor gets
triggered because the contract change
event includes an SLA
aspect as part of the change and it
starts initiating monitoring against the
bigquery table and that requires it to
actually subscribe to arrival events
coming from the control plane about the
bigquery table itself because hey we're
monitoring for the arrival of the table
itself
and of course finally my favorite
example of data management data access
management
let's say we wanted the plane plane
language for give access to all
employees to analytical data only if the
data doesn't have any pii elements seems
so simple
right but what is analytical data well
maybe that's a predicate on the metadata
graph that says all data that's in
either in Snowflake or bigquery or data
breaks or Kafka is analytical and
everything else is operational so you
decide what is analytical for you
and you register that spec into the
control plane
and now you know the drill right there's
an operator that gets triggered
it realizes there's a change in an
access policy that has happened it
starts subscribing to changes it also
can query the metadata to figure out hey
what makes for an analytical data set
and then it sets up access in all of the
individual systems now you can pair it
up with an access management button so
maybe
you know Joe goes to the UI and clicks
please give me access to this data set
and then the access management operator
combines that request for Access with
the policies that are enabled but in the
end you end up provisioning access in
kind of a very nicely decoupled manner
you add one more system into your stack
the only thing that changes is the
integration between the access
management operator and the downstream
system the upper parts of your stack
stay the same
so if uh solved a few use cases very
quickly and but you know what other use
cases would could we tackle with this
architecture turns out quite a few
pretty much all of these examples you
can work them out in your spare time and
they you can use the same template to
solve all of these yet
so the question you might be thinking as
well that sounds like a heavy lift Are
We There Yet how long would it take to
build this
while that gets built can I continue
doing what I'm doing right now
turns out we're not that far
you know if you look at what the data
Hub project has done we've actually
built the data plane observation piece
we're able to extract signals we have a
metadata graph that stores all of this
stuff so those pieces are in good in a
good spot right
the things that are in progress are
actually adding
um declarative specifications so schemas
and data contracts and data product
definitions as control specifications
and supporting registration of those
into the control plane
we've already got a data Hub actions
framework that allows you to listen for
changes and propagate tags into
Snowflake and things like that and so
those are already in progress and
getting evolved on
and State Management is something that
we're planning on working on soon and
we'll probably like not reinvent the
wheel here use something like terraform
or kubernetes as the kind of the back
end uh for State Management
infrastructure
but once we have all of these done you
pretty much have a good MVP for
accomplishing use cases today
so hopefully you know congratulations
you made it through the end
um key takeaways from The Talk data
stack continues to be highly fragmented
thanks to all of you
um the metadata driven control plane is
the only way we can get control back and
bring some order to the chaos where we
need it
data quality data management data
governance these are the areas that will
benefit the most and they can be
harmonized acryl as you might imagine is
building this control plane and we're
not doing it alone of course that would
be foolish we're working with a bunch of
Partners who are collaborating with us
Integrations operators we want to build
a durable control plane and so we want
to work with partners that are willing
to collaborate with us on making sure
that this Integrations stand the test of
time
so if you're interested if you're
building in the space and you want to
collaborate in building out this Vision
come talk to us there's a bunch of
workshops we have a booth a lot of stuff
going on and of course we're all on the
internet so
thanks a lot
[Music]